transgender people don't just want to be
tolerated they want to be celebrated at
Sparkle the largest transgender
gathering in the world there's a freedom
people here can't always enjoy a lot of
people can't express their gender in day
to day life so events like this enable
them to do that some people just come
here for the weekend to express their
gender for that what we can do here
there's growing awareness of a community
which doesn't fall into traditional
gender categories Frank Maloney with the
famous boxing agency
now she's Kelly Maloney and speaks
openly about the reality of change in
gender you don't wake up one morning
just put a dresser and a pair of shoes
and you say I want to be a woman is what
you lose anything I've lost no I'd be
lucky I've not lost as much as never
thought I've lost the most important in
my life my wife you know you said was
very hard a recent poll found that
almost half of people in the UK think
there's nothing morally wrong with
gender reassignment but when it comes to
asking the NHS to pay for the positive
treatment the picture is different only
a quarter of those are but Skye's
exclusive poll results show there are
still social tensions with the over 55
significantly less likely to agree with
gender reassignment than younger people
but a recent string of high-profile
transgender personalities have increased
acceptance from the royal families to
car insurance contour and acclaim TV
series like orange is the new black the
first to feature a transgender character
played by a transgender actress former
Olympic athlete and Kardashian's
stepfather Bruce Jenner recently became
Caitlyn Jenner
receiving the Arthur Ashe award for
courage earlier this week Jena put her
message to the global public to reshape
the landscape of how trans issues are
viewed how trans people are treated and
then more broadly to promote a very
simple idea accepting people for who
they are accepting people's differently
genna's physical transformation mirrors
what many transgender people aim to
achieve at a recent launch for miss
transgender UK the first beauty pageant
of its kind contestant said it was still
a struggle I do believe that we could do
with a little bit more help sit it's
really not easy I mean it's tough
especially for people like me who are
quite naturally masculinity as more
people come out questions about gender
roles and NHS treatments are likely to
mount but so will the demand by
transgender people for true equality
half washed my knees